FRENCESCO NERIERI: So I
bumped into this commercial
the other day from 1979.
Dumb terminals were
really popular back then.
Are you all familiar
with dumb terminals?
It was just a keyboard
and a monitor connected
to a central intelligence,
like a mainframe or a server.
And 1979 is also when
Sony introduced Walkman,
the portable cassette
music player.
I really love these
old commercials.
Now, 35 years later
today, we are literally
surrounded by smart gadgets--
smart watches, smart TVs,
smartphones, and apparently
music playing smart toilets.
And these gadgets are
indeed really smart.
Let's pick just the Nexus 5.
It has a quad-core
2.3 gigahertz.
I mean, I don't know what
was your first computer when
you were in college,
but back then
when I over clocked my Pentium
II Deschutes to something
like 450 megahertz, I thought
I was driving a Ferrari.
That was a tower this tall.
But these gadgets,
they share something
in common with those
dumb terminals.
I'm so used to being always
online, always connected
that I don't even download my
music or my movies anymore.
I use Google Play
musical access,
or Netflix, or Pandora, Spotify.
So for these gadgets to
perform smart operations,
they have to be connected
to an intelligence.
And this intelligence
is the cloud.
In fact, those times that
I find myself offline,
it feels like
something is missing.
And maybe I'm playing a
game like Flappy Bird.
It's a game that can be
really frustrating real fast.
My name is Francesco, and
thanks for joining my session.
Today, I'm introducing
a few Google services
that will let you build
applications that can perform
really smart tasks
and communicate
across all these gadgets
with a minimal effort spent
on developing on the cloud.
And communication is the key,
communication across devices.
For my watch to buzz me that
it's time to jump on stage,
it needs to communicate
with my phone, which
needs to communicate
with the cloud,
and communication among us.
We live in a social
application era.
Twitter, WhatsApp,
Google+, Facebook, Yelp.
We communicate through
these applications
that interoperate by the cloud.
And in Google, we have
a very popular service
that lets your
application interoperate
across these devices.
And it's one of my favorite
products-- Google Cloud
Messaging.
Now, Google Cloud
Messaging is still
experiencing a fantastic growth.
Just from last year, we are
processing now three times
the number of requests.
And this is like 700,000
queries per second,
which is over 60 billion
requests every single day.
And actually now, because
we're in time of a World Cup,
I've seen spikes over a few
million queries per second.
The other day I was checking
the graphs of the GCM requests.
And it was really
funny to see how
you can match one to one the
spikes with the goals scored
by the various teams.
So for example, this is the
unfortunately only good match
for Italy versus England.
And you can see
at 3:00 PM when it
starts, there's a little
buzz, a little chatting.
And then there's a
huge spike, which
is when Italy scores and
England scores right after.
And then finally the
winning goal for Italy.
And at the end, there's a lot of
texting when the match is over.
Today we have over
100,000 applications
that already register with GCM.
But this growth is not destined
to go any slower, because we
just announced a new
member to the Google Cloud
messaging family.
So today, you can send
messages to your application
on every single Android device,
but now you can do more.
Let me introduce GCM for Chrome.
You have the very same APIs--
multi-casting, messages
with payload, send
to sync, all the APIs
that you enjoy in Android.
And you have the
same performance
and you also cap
the very same price.
So to see how this
works in details,
let's imagine that we built
a World Cup application.
The basic idea behind GCM
is that our World Cup server
can send a message to GCM to our
World Cup application via GCM.
And we can reach every single
Android device out there.
And now we can also reach
our World Cup publication
on any single Chrome browser
or Chrome OS machine.
And this is really
important, because now we
can reach the user on the
screen where he's looking at.
So for example, when I
was preparing this deck,
I was sitting on my
couch on my laptop.
If we had the World Cup
application on Chrome,
I could've been notified
that Italy scored right there
in the monitor I was looking at.
To have the Chrome
application work with GCM,
we need to do the same steps
that we do for Android.
So we need first to
register with the service.
So we ask for registration
ID, and we get it from GCM.
And the registration
ID is the address
of the Chrome application
on a given browser.
Just like for Android,
it's the address
of an Android application
on a given Android device.
So now the Chrome application
sends the registration
ID to the World Cup
server, which can now
send a message back
to the application
by addressing it to
the registration ID.
And these registrations
are the same for Android
and for Chrome.
The World Cup
server doesn't even
need to know which one is which.
And because we are living in
this world of multiscreens,
it becomes more and more
important and useful
for us to be able to
target the user rather
than every single device.
So it would be very useful
if you could tell, hey GCM,
we send this message to this
user and now go figure it out.
And today, you can't do that.
Because we are
launching for everybody
the new API user notifications.
And the way this API
works is very simple.
As you have seen, every single
device, every application
on every single device,
sends the registration ID up
to the World Cup
server, which now
has the map in between
the user account, the user
that we signed in in our
World Cup application,
and the registration IDs.
And all we need to do is to
give them mapping to GCM.
And say hey, create this mapping
for a user and my World Cup
app.
And these are all its devices.
So GCM creates a
notification key,
which is the identity of
the user for the World Cup
application.
And now just like before,
we can send a message
and target it to the
notification key to the user
itself.
And GCM delivers it to all of
these devices and endpoints
as they become available.
So now you can send a message
and target me if you say,
Italy scored a goal.
And we pop the notification
on all of my devices,
on all of my screens.
But because now we're seeing
this notification everywhere,
it becomes more important
that we synchronize
the dismissal of
this notification.
If I see that Italy
scored on my watch,
as much as I like
that notification,
I don't want to see
it again on my tablet.
So when we act on
the notification,
we need a way to dismiss
it everywhere else.
And today we can
do that, because we
are launching for everyone--
Upstream Messaging.
Now, let's deep dive on an
example to see how this works.
Let's assume that we
have a tablet and a phone
and our World Cup
application on both.
So first, we receive a
message which Italy scored.
And we put the notification on
the system tray of our devices.
And this is the code.
On the broadcast receiver,
we get the message.
We look inside the message.
We see the text, Italy
one, England zero.
And we get the identifier,
which is unique.
So we built a notification
with the notification manager.
And we pop it on the
notification tray.
Now I'm closer to my phone,
and I look at the notification
right there.
So what I do, I act on it.
And what we need to do is
send an upstream message
to dismiss the notification.
Here we are building a message.
We grab the notification ID.
We set the action
to be dismissal.
And we address it to the
user, to the notification key,
which is the identity of
the user for our World Cup
application.
The GCM does the rest.
It gets the message and
delivers it to the tablet.
And now just like before, the
tablet receives the message
from the broadcast receiver,
sees the notification ID,
and just call
NotifcationManager.Cancel.
It is really simple,
and yet very powerful.
But upstream messaging,
just as the name suggests,
lets us do more.
We can send messages
back out to our server
by using the GCM infrastructure.
For example, we
could say, hey, we
want to follow the next
match, USA versus Portugal.
And upstream messaging
is very useful
because it persists
the message for us.
Once we give it to GCM,
even if there is no network,
even if the phone reboots,
the GCM stores it locally.
So as soon as it has a chance
to send it, it will do that.
But for this to work,
the World Cup server
needs to be connected to GCM.
And today, we are going
to launch for everybody
a new service, which is the
Cloud Connection Service.
With this service, we
allow you to open up
to 100 parallel persisting
connections with the XMPP
protocol to GCM.
And you can stream messages
through these 100 connections
as fast as you can.
So the World Cup server opens
this XMPP connection to GCM.
And it authenticates with a
classic PROJECT_ID and API_Key.
Now, if our Chrome
applications want
to send the message back
to the World Cup server
saying we want to follow the
match between Portugal and US,
then all we need to do
is to pack a message
and address it to
the PROJECT_ID, which
is the user that the
World Cup server used
to authenticate the connection.
And that's all you
need to do, because GCM
will look through the pool
of healthy connections
from our World Cup server and
will pick one randomly and send
a message to that server.
Now sometimes, we might
need to drain a connection.
And we want to do that
in a graceful way.
So if you receive
such a message,
connection draining,
then all you need to do
is to stop sending new messages,
let the in flight messages
complete, then close the
connection and open a new one.
So now you can stream
all these messages
over these 100 connections.
And GCM eventually is
going to deliver them.
And I'm saying eventually
because as you all know,
devices go online and
offline at all times.
In fact, it will be really
useful to know sometimes
for some use cases
when actually GCM
sent a message to
a specific device.
So let me introduce
a brand new API
that we launched
for everybody today
which is GCM Delivery Receipt.
What this API does for you
is that when the World Cup
server sends a
message to GCM, let's
assume that our browser
is disconnected for now.
As soon as the World Cup
application in Chrome
connects to GCM, then
we deliver the message.
And then we send the receipt
back to the World Cup server.
And the way you activate
this API is very simple.
When you send a
message, you just
specify that you want
to have a receipt.
And if you do so, the
receipt message you get back
looks like this one.
We tell you which device
we sent the message to,
specify by the registration
ID, and the timestamp
when we sent the message.
And because we really care
about this multiscreen world,
we want to make this
delivery receipt
work with a user
notification API as well.
So in the example before,
if you send a message to me,
to the user, now GCM will send
a receipt back for every message
and for every device we
deliver this message to.
So if Chrome connects
first, we send a receipt
with a registration ID of
the Chrome application.
As soon as Android connects,
we do the same for my phone
and then for the TV as well.
It is important to note
the delivery receipt,
it works at the
GCM protocol level.
So in an example could be I
want to send a private message
to my friend in London
that Italy scored.
And he will be notified when the
message is sent to his device.
I want to make sure he is
actually watching the game.
For that, this is the best API.
But then we also want to know
if my friend read the message.
And that's a delivery receipt
at the application level.
And for that, the best API
is, again, upstream messaging.
In fact, upstream
messaging is a great API
for all sorts of
ephemeral messages,
like the user presence
in a conversation
leaves for an instant
messaging application.
And not only because we do
persistency for the messages,
not only because we take away
the network troubles for you,
but also we give GCM a
chance to batch messages
together and save battery life.
If many applications sends
messages upstream using GCM,
then GCM can collect
them together.
And mind that every time
we wake up the radio,
we consume battery life.
In fact, there are other
sorts of network calls,
all the background
network calls that are
great to be able
to batch together.
For example, if
your application,
if our World Cup application
wants to upload logs
and statistics, we don't
need to do that in real time.
We can say something
like, schedule
me to run in the next
hour and upload my logs.
So these kind of calls are
perfect to be collected
and batched together so that we
can wake up the radio only one
times instead of multiple times.
So today, let me
introduce a new service
that will let us
do exactly this.
That's Google Cloud
Messaging Network Manager.
And the APIs for this new
service are really simple.
There are two main APIs.
The first, you can
schedule a task
and you specify a time window.
For example, the example
before, I ran my upload
in the next hour,
whenever you want to.
And then you can
schedule periodic tasks.
You can say, hey, run my stats
upload every three hours,
but run me only in the first 20
minutes of each of those three
hours period.
And this is a code example
for exactly this use case.
And so now we have
those 20 minutes
to be able to batch
things together.
For example, we are
receiving different tasks
from different applications.
But Network Manager
does something
even smarter-- it
listens to other signals.
So in this case, even if we
have five more minutes to wait,
GCM sends a message that Italy
scored and wakes up the radio.
So the Network
Manager might decide
this is the right time
to run all those tasks.
And instead of waking
up the radio five times,
now we did it only once.
But piggybacking on the
message from the cloud.
And in fact, to maximize the
chances for Network Manager
to do the best it can
to save battery life,
in the previous example the
best would have been to say,
schedule me to run every
three hours whenever
you want during that
three hours period.
So Network Manager is great
because it persists our tasks.
If our application gets killed,
we wake up the application
when we need to run your task.
And same goes if device reboots.
It also takes care of
network issues for us.
It does retries in
case of flakiness.
If the job fails, it
will retry for us.
If the server is busy, it will
do exponential back off for us.
And plus, it will try to
do the smart things to save
as much battery life as you can.
So let's check what
we have seen so far.
We first introduced
GCM for Chrome.
Now we can target
our application
on any Android device and on
any Chrome browser and Chrome OS
machine.
And you can read more at
developer.chrome.com/apps/gcm.
And there is also an I/O
Bytes recording on YouTube
from Phillip, one of
the engineers behind GCM
for Chrome.
Then we introduced
four new APIs.
The User Notification
that lets you
target the user so that
GCM sends the message
to all of its devices.
The upstream
messaging that lets us
synchronize
notification dismissal.
The Cloud Connection
Server that let us
stream messages up to
100 parallel connections.
And delivery receipt that inform
our server when we actually
send a message to
a given device.
And finally, we introduced
the Network Manager.
We peaked a little
bit in the future.
Because even if this service
is not rolled out yet,
it's part of the
Play Services API.
So as soon as we're
going to roll it out,
it'll be present on any
device that is GCM capable.
So communications.
Communication across users and
communication across devices.
You've seen how we
can target the user
and reach it on all of the
screens for our World Cup
application by just giving
the mapping between a user
account and all the
registration IDs to GCM.
And GCM creates the
notification key,
which is the identity of
the user for our World Cup
application.
An identity is a
great concept and let
us do really cool stuff.
For example, if we address
a message to an identity,
to a user, to me
right now, it's great
if you can send this message to
my watch, my phone, and maybe
my Chrome tablet here.
But you should leave
my tablet at home
alone because there's no need
to waste its battery over there,
because there's no chance for me
to read the message right there
right now.
And identity let us
do even cooler stuff.
We have seen on the
keynote in other sessions
that by having
the watch with me,
I can keep my phone unlocked.
And by having my phone
unlocked in my pocket,
it can tell the surrounding
devices with my account
that it's me.
So if I walk towards
my Chrome machine,
it can keep my Chrome
machine unlocked
as long as we have
the same account.
And Google provides us
with a very simple way
to log in our users in
our World Cup application
with a Google account.
And this is not just
great because we
don't have to invent or
implement the whole account
system, but also because
the majority of users
that have Android devices
that are capable of GCM
already have a
Google account in it.
So when our user click on
our World Cup application,
then we can automatically
log the user in.
No speed bumps for
sign ups, no passwords.
And then we can bring the login
information back to our servers
if we want to by just
creating an identity token.
We call the
GoogleAuthUtil.getToken.
We pass the accountName.
And the account name is
exactly the same account
we just used to sign
the Google user in.
And identity's a key concept
behind synchronization as well.
Let's imagine that we want
to add this functionality
to our World Cup application.
We want to let our
user specify which
is their favorite team, which
is their favorite player,
and also set some reminders.
For example, the next
match I'm interested in
is about to start.
So remind me that I
need to buy some beer.
To build this, let
me introduce the all
new Google Cloud Save APIs.
Google Cloud Save let us
store data in the cloud
and synchronize it
across all the users end
points as they go
online and offline.
And the data you store
is owned by you, just
like if you store it
in your own server.
The synchronization
is powered by GCM,
and it has full offline support.
So we don't need to
take care of the radio.
And APIs are really,
really simple.
You can save, delete, and
query the data of your users.
And if you need to, you
can also force the sync.
And the way you use this is
just by telling the Google API
client that you want
to add a new API, which
is the Cloud Save Manager API.
And here you pass the
account that we just
used to sign our user
in, the Google account.
The main storage concept behind
Google Cloud Save is an entity.
And an entity is comprised
of a kind and of a name.
And you can think of a kind
as the table in your database
and the name as the
value of a primary care.
And now it gets really powerful,
because you can dynamically
add column to each table in
the form of key value pairs.
So back to our
example, if you want
to let a user specify
what's their favorite team
and what's their
favorite player,
we create an entity
whose kind is Preference.
The name is team.
And now we add the properties.
Country Italy and the
goal keeper is Buffon.
There is an in depth session
tomorrow about the simplicity
and the power of the
cloud save APIs, which
I suggest you to attend from
[? Justin ?] and Manfred.
But for now, let's
see what we have.
Now, we build an application
that can log in a user
it with the Google identity.
They can store some
data in the cloud.
They can synchronize this
data across our devices.
For example, if
we're on a tablet.
And it can remind us that
it's time to buy some beer.
And we can do all this
without spending or writing
a single line of
code up in the cloud.
As you can see, we have,
again, multiple notifications
and we want to dismiss them.
And because we are using
the Google identity,
even dismissal of
notification gets simpler.
Now, we don't need a server to
dismiss these notifications,
because we can use the user
notification API in combination
with a Google identity.
And here is how it works.
When we first install our
application on a phone
and our World Cup application
tells GCM, hey, add this user,
this Google account,
this Google identity
to the notification key and
this is my registration ID.
But GCM doesn't have a
notification key yet.
So it creates one for
this Google account
and adds the registration ID
for our World Cup application
on that form.
Now as the user installs the
application on more devices,
for example the tablet, the
tablet does the same thing.
Say hey, add this Google
account to the notification key
and this is my registration ID.
Now GCM has the
notification key.
It just simply adds the
device to the group.
So back to your
application now, we
can simply dismiss
the beer reminder,
just as we've seen in
the previous slides.
So with a Google identity,
Cloud Save, and the user
notifications API, we have built
a really powerful application
that let us specify user
preferences, reminders,
synchronize the
data across devices,
and synchronize this
missile, and we still
haven't written a single
line of code in the cloud.
And all this because Cloud
Save generates a server for us.
It generates it on
the Google Cloud.
It generates an App
Engine server for us.
So now we can stop here, or
we can log in in the cloud
and do really wonderful things.
We can go up there, unleash
the power of big data,
unleash the power of App
Engine, add some code,
and run analysis and
statistics on our user's data,
because we own the data.
We, the developer,
do own the data.
And because we have a
server now, we can add APIs.
So our Chrome Web
application that
logs our user in with
the same identity
can act on the cloud save data.
And now we can add the
original functionality.
We want to tell the user
when his favorite team
during the game is scoring.
So we can use GCM and send the
message to the individual end
points or use GCM and target
the identity of the user
so we can reach
him on the screens
where it matters the most.
And this is the power of
the Google Mobile Cloud.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
If you have questions,
we can take on the mic.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So [INAUDIBLE] the
offline message.
So if your
application's not online
and you send a notification,
will this message
get delivered when
the user gets online?
FRENCESCO NERIERI: So in
GCM, if the device where
the application is is offline?
AUDIENCE: Right.
So you have multiple users.
And one user
distributed the message.
But you have one
device not online.
Maybe like when you send out a
notification, it's not online.
But later on, it gets
online, will this message
become an offline message?
FRENCESCO NERIERI: So
if you have two devices.
One is online and
one is offline.
And you target the user,
so GCM sends to both.
You send the message
to the online device.
As soon as the second
device gets online, then
we deliver the
message there as well.
AUDIENCE: So you cache
the message on server?
FRENCESCO NERIERI:
Yes, unless-- so there
is a feature on GCM that
is called Time to Live.
You can specify an amount of
time before a message expires.
And if you set the
time to live to zero,
when we receive the message
if the device is offline,
then we just drop the message.
We'll never see it.
Otherwise, we store
it in the cloud
until the device comes online.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: The Cloud Save seems
like a really simple function
to add.
Say I incorporate
that into my app.
Much later, can I access
that data in the cloud
with an app running in the
cloud with functionality running
in the cloud to do new
things to that data?
FRENCESCO NERIERI: Yes.
So Cloud Save has the
account counterpart
that has its own APIs.
Not only you can access
it through the App Engine
as you log in up there, but
you can, as I was saying,
you can expose APIs so that
your own server can also
access the data.
AUDIENCE: A question
on Cloud Save as well.
It looks like it's simply a
simplified API for data store.
So to what level does it expose
the data store functionality?
And for example, can
I do a transaction?
Can I implement the
fact even in my app
I give a token to someone else?
FRENCESCO NERIERI:
So in Android,
we try to simplify the APIs as
much as possible to abstract
the cloud, the
part of the cloud.
But yes, the API
that we've exposed
can get more complicated and can
actually do all those things.
I suggest you do follow
the session tomorrow,
go in details on
all of these things.
AUDIENCE: So it sounded
like Cloud Save does
stuff where it would
sync if it was offline,
and then when it comes
online, it would sync.
How do you deal with
conflicts, like if you
had saved the same thing
on two different devices?
FRENCESCO NERIERI:
So we have a way
to deal with conflict
resolution, which
is a simple way.
We give you back
the basic entity--
the remote and the local entity.
And then you'll
extend the function.
And then you just
deal with the conflict
and give us back the
results so we just
synchronize with the cloud.
AUDIENCE: Is Google Cloud
Save free to use like the GCM?
FRENCESCO NERIERI: The terms on
this are still to be decided.
AUDIENCE: OK.
FRENCESCO NERIERI: I can't
speculate on that, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Is the concept of
users tied to Google accounts,
or can it be local users as
well in your application?
Like outside of using-- so is it
tied to Google accounts, or is
it can be separate?
FRENCESCO NERIERI:
For Cloud Save?
AUDIENCE: No, not the Cloud
Save, but for user messaging.
FRENCESCO NERIERI: Yeah, so
the user notification actually
allows you to do both.
You can use the Google
identity or your own account.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
Thank you.
FRENCESCO NERIERI: Thank you.
I'll be at the Android booth if
you guys have more questions.
[APPLAUSE]